And finally, New Rule,
It's time to admit
President Trump has actually
accomplished one good thing.
He's ruined the phrase,
"thoughts and prayers" forever.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
Of course, the problem with
"thoughts and prayers"
has always been that thoughts
are the opposite of prayers.
-(LAUGHTER)
-One is from-- (LAUGHS)
One is from the Enlightenment
and one is from The Exorcist.
(ANA CHUCKLES) Oh, my God.
But it wasn't until Trump
tweeted his thoughts and prayers
after the Parkland shooting
and one of the survivors
tweeted back,
"I don't want your condolences
you fucking piece of shit...
Prayers won't fix this,"
that "prayer" officially
became an eye roll.
Yes, America's finally
getting it.
Prayer doesn't work,
'cause if it did,
every drug test
would come back clean,
-and there'd be--
-(ANA CHUCKLES)
(LAUGHTER)
(SCATTERED APPLAUSE)
And there'd be no need
for the morning-after pill.
-(LAUGHTER)
-(ANA CHUCKLES)
But it's more than just prayer.
Thanks to Trump, piety itself
has ceased to be a third rail
in American politics.
How could it anymore,
when the world's least Godly man
has been so fully embraced
by our most religious people,
the Evangelicals?
Oh, they love them
some Donald Trump,
a man who's been to church
four times in his whole life,
three of them to get married.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
The only time he touches a Bible
is for depositions-- (CHUCKLES)
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
And if he ever went
to confession,
they'd have to take
a meal break.
(LAUGHTER)
He-- (CHUCKLES) He's into golden
showers, not the golden rule.
(AUDIENCE GROANS)
-(CHEERING)
-(ANA GIGGLES)
-(APPLAUSE)
-It's...
It's true.
He does not tweet people
the way he wants to be tweeted.
(LAUGHTER)
So when Trump got his mulligan
from the values voters,
that's when we knew religion
had jumped the shark,
and it was finally safe to say,
"None for me, thanks,
I had bullshit for lunch."
Look at some of
these recent examples.
Billy Graham.
My entire life, I've watched
presidents from both parties
suck up to this blowhard,
like he was the American Gandhi,
but when he died last month,
it got covered
like Olympic curling.
"Local storyteller dead at 99."
Omarosa, last week,
openly mocked Mike Pence
for believing Jesus
"tells him to say things."
Mocked by Omarosa?
It's like getting dumped on
by Kevin Hart.
(LAUGHTER)
Even Oprah was widely
made fun of when she said,
"God, if you think I'm supposed
to run for president,
you gotta tell me,
and it has to be so clear
that not even I can miss it."
And a lot of America said,
"Oh, please,
not the, 'I have to check
with my imaginary friend'
excuse."
Which was bad enough when
people like Scott Walker said,
"I am certain:
This is God's plan for me."
Something God also told
Rick Perry, Rick Santorum,
Ben Carson, Michelle Bachmann,
Herman Cain, Sarah Palin...
God is a nice guy,
but he doesn't follow politics.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
But, folks, this is progress.
I used to be
a lonely pioneer here,
calling religious thinking
a neurological disorder, but...
now, it's like anal,
everyone's doing it.
(LAUGHTER)
And in that, there is a lesson
for the Democrats.
Things that used
to be third rails
don't have
to be third rails forever.
Republicans get that.
For 50 years their fundamental
principles were,
"Law enforcement, good,
Russia, bad."
And then, it was Freaky Friday.
(LAUGHTER)
Twenty years ago,
the idea of arming teachers
was universally derided.
But now,
while we point and laugh,
they're doing it!
Democrats, on the other hand,
begin every
gun conversation with,
"I support
the Second Amendment."
(SCOFFS)
'Cause they fear this is
one of those third rails
that can never be touched.
Even shooting victims,
the minute they wake up
from their coma,
their first words are,
"I still support
the Second Amendment."
Now, would it be a hard slog
to change the public's mind
on guns? Of course.
But a hard slog
never fazes Conservatives.
Ronald Reagan used to be a joke.
Now, he's an airport.
(LAUGHTER)
(SCATTERED APPLAUSE)
The Second Amendment is
just words humans made up
at a certain moment in History
when they felt right.
It's an Amendment,
not a Commandment.
-And we could make up--
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
(WHISTLING)
And we could make up
new words again.
Instead of, "The right of
the people to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed,"
we could change it to,
"The right of the people
to apply for the privilege
of possessing non-military style
weaponry, as long as
they're not bat-shit crazy,
-shall not be infringed."
-(CHEERING AND APPLAUSE)
Sorry, Trump, no guns for you.
All right!